warning the following video contains
spoilers it's a freaking reaction video
what do you expect is it just me or does
that Titan have a really nice ass no
faster mummy swing me faster who playing
guess the spy okay okay okay I got this
one I go this one does she look like a
[ __ ]
come at me bro can we please sort out
this female Titan by the end of the
episodes that's right Aaron if you've
learned something from this show you
should always trust the power of
friendship yeah that's [ __ ] take this
[ __ ] down hashtag Yolo please might
just want just let humanity win just
just once that things go right and no
one has done okay
hold everything time out guys time out
okay so what's gonna be one of my usual
reactions to this episode since you know
I fought out you've recorded and edited
it but then I was like you know what
that video would be alive cuz that won't
be my real reaction so I thought I'd do
a video of my raw reaction which is
something more like for 20 minutes
straight actually no it'd be more like
10 minutes of doing that then the
remaining 10 minutes would be me raging
I was someone to kill that [ __ ]
female Titan and one minute of me raging
at aaron from not being able to punch
someone in the face correctly how hard
can it [ __ ] be twice okay now you're
just taking the pit along with getting
eaten for a second time
again freaking again but yeah all joking
aside this was one of the best anime
episodes I've seen all year now I was
actually thinking that's happened Titan
was kind of losing his charm for a bit
there since this art with the female
Titan has just drags on for so long and
then this episode happened I don't know
me gets so emotionally involved in an
anime anymore but these 20 minutes were
just a rollercoaster feels if something
called the fuel train existed this
episode would be it kinda like this ride
anymore mom can I get off cuz you know
what we got to see the whole of team
Levi be annihilated well I mean the
three guys I didn't really care about
cuz quite remember the names but Petra
died Petra well she looks pretty
petrified I'm going to hell
and you know by the end of the episode I
was sad for a bit I just didn't know
what to do no maybe crawl up in the
fetal position for a bit
calm down by reading some of Anne
Frank's diary watch some rec room for a
dream maybe something that just had
a lighter tone than what I just
witnessed why do you do this to me your
Sakhalin tighten well I can't think just
go well for once why do people die when
they are killed and this was a big
turning point for me because I haven't
actually been the shot since frickin
Aaron died or he did die again today but
he didn't really die
you just got eaten whatever ah dope but
yeah that's my drawer reaction for you
guys who requested it I don't think I'll
do another reaction like this for a
while as usual I'll be watching the rest
of attack on Titan on crunchyroll
so you can go to crunch wall or COMSAT
Academy zone for a free month or premium
membership if you want to see some of my
other reaction videos to some attack on
Titan episodes well I've already done a
few but they're a bit different for this
one where you can check them out too and
as always you can find me on Facebook
and Twitter in the description below
anyway I'm gonna get ready for our con
in 1 or 2 days even though I'm still in
Thailand but until then I've been gig up
and I'll see you all next time